sería bueno que nos preparáramos
bastante bien para resolver sistemas de
ecuaciones y entender bastante bien qué
es lo que pasa por si alguna vez en
nuestra vida nos topamos a alguna regla
por ahí ahora date cuenta que no siempre
vamos a tener un pájaro que hable que
nos ayude por lo tanto vamos a hacer un
repaso de todo lo que hemos visto para
ver si podemos resolver este tipo de
problemas para eso déjame pasar primero
a mis notas aquí justo aquí tengo la
pantalla que estábamos viendo en el
vídeo pasado pero déjenme bajar un poco
la pantalla para que trabajemos un poco
en el resumen sobre todo lo que hemos
visto así que déjenme bajar un poco por
aquí la pantalla de ahora voy a trabajar
en un pequeño resumen de todo lo que
hemos visto fíjate bien si yo tengo por
aquí a mí y ok y por aquí tengo a mi eje
x ok y tengo dos rectas voy a suponer
que una de ellas
déjame ponerlo así una de ellas es esta
de aquí y me voy a tomar ahora a otra
recta que va a ser más o menos esta de
por aquí si las dos rectas se
intersectan en
punto entonces solamente tienen una
solución si se intersectan en un punto
deben de tener solamente una solución
una sola
y en este caso decíamos que este era un
sistema consistente déjame ponerlo así
este es un sistema consistente ok y por
lo tanto deberíamos de tener dos
ecuaciones que fueran independientes son
dos ecuaciones independientes y
dependientes y este es el mejor de los
panoramas independientes ok y este es el
mejor de los panoramas también podemos
tener otro panorama que no sea tan
prometedor pero bueno también no esté
tan mal en el dado caso de que voy a
dibujar aquí mi eje xy por acá voy a
dibujar a miguel guillén ok en el dado
caso de que tengamos una recta voy a
suponer que esta es mi primera recta ok
y después tenga otra recta y sea la
misma recta es decir en el caso en el
que tenga dos veces
la misma recta una aquí y la otra kim ok
y en este caso si te das cuenta decimos
que tenemos una infinidad de soluciones
cada uno de los puntos
solución de este sistema de ecuaciones
entonces o espera déjame cambio de
herramienta en este caso tengo una
infinidad una infinidad de soluciones
soluciones y bueno en este caso decíamos
que teníamos un sistema consistente y es
un sistema consistente porque tenemos
solución tenemos hecho una infinidad de
soluciones consistentes ok pero
estábamos diciendo que era un caso en el
que las ecuaciones eran dependientes
dependientes dependientes dependientes
porque de hecho hablábamos de que una
ecuación era exactamente igual que la
otra ahora este es el primer caso es la
primera opción esta es la segunda opción
pero también tenemos una tercera opción
para esto déjenme mover un poco la
pantalla aunque me voy a mover un poco
para acá y vamos a poner aquí la tercera
de mis opciones mi tercera opción me
dice que también tengo por aquí al eje
de las x ok por aquí tengo al eje de la
siesta ok pero puedo tener dos rectas
y las voy a poner con el mismo color que
nunca se intersectan imagínate tú que
tengo aquí a una de ellas y la otra es
estar aquí tengo otro por aquí que es
exactamente esta de aquí y si te das
cuenta estas dos rectas nunca se
intersectan entonces en este caso
decimos que no tenemos solución déjame
ponerlo así y no tenemos solución no hay
solución solución ok y en este caso
tenemos un sistema inconsistente porque
precisamente no tenemos solución y
consistente inconsistente y con esto
concluimos que no tenemos solución ahora
déjame ver si puedo hacer un poco más
pequeña toda esta pantalla déjame hacer
un poco más pequeña todo este resumen
porque lo voy a mover para acá ok un
poco y lo que quiero que pensemos es
acerca de lo que nos queda es decir las
ecuaciones en el primer caso y déjenme
cambiar ahora a este color en el primer
caso tenemos diferentes pendientes si
nosotros tenemos una única solución
así que tenemos dos rectas con distintas
pendientes entonces lo voy a poner aquí
distintas distintas pendientes
pendientes y eso es muy importante si
tenemos distintas pendientes
forzosamente vamos a tener una única
solución y por lo tanto es un sistema
consistente y son ecuaciones
independientes ok pero en el caso de que
tengamos un sistema consistente pero las
ecuaciones sean dependientes es decir
que tengamos una infinidad de soluciones
tenemos la misma pendiente la misma
pendiente pendiente ok si tenemos la
misma pendiente puede ser un sistema
consistente y puede ser que tengamos
unas ecuaciones dependientes si tenemos
un sistema inconsistente que crees
también tenemos la misma pendiente misma
pendiente
y podemos decir eso porque date cuenta
que son dos rectas paralelas y las
rectas paralelas tienen la misma
pendiente en este caso es la misma recta
y la misma recta tiene la misma
pendiente la diferencia entre este caso
y este caso es que en este caso tenemos
la misma intersección con el eje de
asies ok la misma vez y en este caso
tenemos dos veces distintas
es decir la intersección con el eje de
arias es una en la primera recta y en la
segunda recta es otra tenemos distintas
intersecciones con el eje de la jr
entonces si tenemos distintas pendientes
podemos concluir que es un sistema
consistente y tenemos ecuaciones
independientes y por lo tanto vamos a
tener una única solución si tenemos la
misma pendiente hay de dos casos o que
tengamos la misma intersección con el
eje de aries si la tenemos entonces son
sistemas consistentes pero son
ecuaciones dependientes y entonces
tenemos una infinidad de soluciones o en
el dado caso tenemos la misma pendiente
pero intersecciones distintas con el eje
de las íes y en ese caso tenemos un
sistema inconsistente
por lo tanto no tenemos solución ok ya
que tenemos este repaso pues vamos a
intentar resolver los ejercicios que
están en la página vamos a abrir el
explorador de internet por aquí ok y
ahora que lo tenemos aquí vamos a
intentar resolver estos problemas
determina cuántas soluciones existen
para el siguiente sistema de ecuaciones
y tengo estas dos ecuaciones menos 6 x
más esto es igual a 1 menos 12 x más 2
esto es igual a 2 ahora creo que date
cuenta que si dividimos la ecuación
número 2 la ecuación de verde entre 2
todos los dividimos entre 2 vamos a
llegar a la misma ecuación que tenemos
acá arriba menos 12 entre 2 es menos 62
y entre 2 es bien 2 entre 2 es 1 por lo
tanto tenemos la misma ecuación y cuando
tenemos la misma ecuación esto es de una
manera muy fácil y muy sencilla podemos
decir que es la misma recta y si tenemos
la misma recta entonces tenemos
infinidad de soluciones tenemos un
sistema consistente pero dependiente y
bueno si no estás muy seguro podemos
pedir una pista entonces vamos a pedir
convierte ambas ecuaciones en la forma
pendiente intersección con el eje la que
es y si las convertimos la primera es la
forma que igual a 6 x + 1 ok mientras
que la segunda es la forma es igual a 6
x + 1 llegamos a lo mismo tenemos la
misma pendiente la misma razón de cambio
que 6 y la misma intersección con el eje
de las 10 la misma intersección con el
eje de las 10
entonces dos rectas que tienen la misma
pendiente y la misma intersección con el
eje de asies son rectas consistentes
pero son sistemas dependientes y por lo
tanto tenemos
una infinidad de soluciones
comprobaremos la respuesta de lujo vamos
a la siguiente pregunta y dice determina
cuántas soluciones existen para el
siguiente sistema de ecuaciones otra vez
y en esta ocasión tengo menos x más e
igual a menos 4 menos 3 x + 3g igual a
menos 12 y creo que es el mismo caso si
nosotros dividimos la ecuación número 2
entre 3 llegamos a la ecuación de azul
así que vamos a ver me gustaría una
pista vamos a transformarlo todo en la
forma pendiente intersección con el gel
así es
pendiente ordenada al origen y llegamos
a las mismas rectas por lo tanto a es la
misma recta tienen la misma pendiente
que es 1 la misma intersección con el
dif y de leyes y es el mismo caso
anterior por lo tanto tenemos infinitas
soluciones y comprobamos respuesta vamos
a la que sigue y dice menos 2x más y
esto es igual a menos 9 y igual a 2 x +
date cuenta que la ecuación de abajo ya
está en la forma pendiente ordenada al
origen pendiente intersección con el eje
de las 10 mientras que la de arriba no
pero de una manera muy fácil hasta
inclusive mentalmente podemos ver que
esta ecuación de acá arriba cuando
nosotros despejamos hay en este 12 x
pasa del otro lado positivo y entonces
me quedaría y es igual a 2 x menos 9 lo
que quiere decir que tenemos dos rectas
con la misma pendiente la pendiente es 2
pero tenemos distinta intersección con
el eje de las 10 en la primera tenemos
la intersección de menos 9 y en la
segunda 7 y por lo tanto tenemos dos
rectas con la misma pendiente y que
interceptan al eje de las 10 en puntos
distintos por lo tanto
tenemos un sistema inconsistente y los
sistemas inconsistentes no tienen
solución así que de todas maneras vamos
a corroborarlo con una pista pedimos una
pista lo vamos a pasar a ambas
ecuaciones en la forma pendiente
ordenada al origen ok
la otra ya estaba y por lo tanto date
cuenta que tenemos la misma pendiente en
la misma pendiente la pendiente es 2
pero tenemos una distinta intersección
con el eje de las 10 en la primera es 9
en la segunda y 7 y en este caso estamos
diciendo que tenemos un sistema
inconsistente entonces comprobemos la
respuesta de lujo vamos a la siguiente
ok
tengo este caso de aquí pero este caso
de aquí es muy fácil fíjate bien tenemos
las mismas ecuaciones y si tenemos las
mismas ecuaciones pues hablamos de la
misma recta y si estamos hablando de la
misma recta de una forma muy rápida
podemos decir que tenemos infinitas
soluciones porque tenemos un sistema
consistente pero con ecuaciones
dependientes entonces comprobemos
respuesta y vamos en la siguiente
pregunta dice menos 3 x menos james esto
es igual a menos 9 2 x más esto es igual
a 8 bueno quiero que te des cuenta de
que para resolver este caso que tenemos
aquí lo que sería mejor sería pasarlo de
la forma pendiente ordenada al origen
pero también lo podemos hacer de una
manera intuitiva que quiere decir que
por cada menos 3x que nosotros tenemos
estamos cambiando menos un ayer mientras
que el de acá abajo decimos que por cada
2 x que tenemos estamos cambiando una
guía y por lo tanto creo que suena que
tenemos distintas pendientes y cuando
tenemos distintas pendientes el caso es
muy fácil porque solamente tenemos una
solución la solución sería el punto en
donde se intersectan estas dos rectas
por lo tanto es un sistema consistente
con ecuaciones independientes el único
caso que nos faltaba pero de todas
maneras vamos a ver con una pista si
llegamos a eso vamos a poner las dos
ecuaciones en la forma pendiente
ordenada de origen ok
la primera me queda como oye es igual a
menos 3 x 9 eso quiere decir que la
pendiente es menos 3 y que la ordenada
al origen la intersección con el eje de
la siesta es 9 y fíjate que la pendiente
lo que me dice aquí es que la razón de
cambio de x a comparación de ella es que
por cada una unidad que cambiemos en x
vamos a bajar 3 unidades en 10 ok y
vamos a ver qué pasa con la otra me
gusta en una pista y en la otra recta me
dice que tengo
la ecuación pendiente ordenar al origen
de la forma y es igual a menos 2 x más 8
ok en este caso tenemos una pendiente de
menos 2 y una intersección con el eje de
la 78 ok y date cuenta que la pendiente
está pendiente lo que me dice es que la
razón de cambio de x comparación de
james es que por cada unidad que yo me
mueva en x voy a bajar 2 en ya tenemos
distintas pendientes y cuando tenemos
distintas pendientes de una manera muy
rápida podemos concluir que tenemos una
única solución el sistema es consistente
es independiente y entonces tenemos
distintas pendientes y una solución
comprobemos respuesta perfecto eso es
todo por este vídeo